Німецький уряд дав зелене світло
на виведення контингенту Бундесверу
з турецької авіабази "Інджирлік".
Що робили німецькі військові в Туреччині
та чому мають піти?
На базі "ІнджирлІк" перебували
близько 260 військових Бундесверу.
Вони брали участь в операціях
міжнародної коаліції
проти терористичного угруповання "Ісламська держава",
зокрема здійснювали розвідувальні польоти
в небі над Сирією.
Після рішення німецького уряду
військових та літаки Бундесверу  перекинуть
на базу "Аль-Асрак" в Йорданії.
Це спричинить перерву у польотах Tornado
орієнтовно на два місяці.
Нині в уряді мають з’ясувати,
коли розпочнеться процес передислокації
та хто зможе замінити Бундесвер
у місії на цей час.
Конфлікт між Німеччиною і Туреччиною
довкола "Інджирліка" спалахнув у середині травня.
Тоді Анкара заборонила
відвідини бази депутатам Бундестагу.
На такий крок турецька влада
пішла після того, як Берлін
надав притулок військовим -
опонентам Ердогана, яких переслідують в Туреччині.
У ФРН назвали цю заборону
"абсолютно неприйнятною".
Навзаєм Анкара обіцяла зробити "два кроки назустріч" Берліну,
якщо той
зробить "крок вперед".
А саме - екстрадує військових, яким на батьківщині
закидають організацію путчу торік у липні.
Залагодити конфлікт з Туреччиною
днями спробував міністр закордонних справ ФРН
Зіґмар Ґабріель.
Проте переговори з турецьким коллегою
бажаного результату не дали.
ФРН не має вибору,
як вивести свої сили з бази,
заявив голова МЗС Німеччини.
Відносини між Туреччиною та Німеччиною
значно погіршилися за останні два роки.
Виведення німецьких військових
з бази "Інджирлік", на думку оглядачів,
стане іще одним тягарем
для не надто приязних відносин між країнами.
Військовий контингент Бундесверу
на базі "Інджирлік"
був засобом впливу Ердогана на Німеччину.
Нині ж, після його втрати,
Анкара, як прогнозують експерти,
шукатиме інший важіль тиску
на Берлін. Експерти єдині в одному:
конфлікт навколо бази "Інджирлік"
аж ніяк не сприяє
боротьбі з тероризмом.